all right this is it
first live hey babe it's done it's a
done deal august 24th royersford
pennsylvania two shows we're doing a
live hey babe you can get tickets at
christycomedy.com or
volcanocomedy.com or
souljoles with an ass.com we're doing
soul joel's comedy dome royceford
pennsylvania the tickets are almost sold
out we may add two more shows get the
tickets now our first live hey babe ever
you have to be in the crowd a lot of big
surprises it's gonna be a one for the
ages for sure for sure yeah there's only
one first babe there's only one first
come lose your virginity with us at the
live hey bib if you're in the front row
wear a poncho august 24th
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey
[Music]
this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-a-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is
y b bananas
b e this [ __ ] is bananas h e y b a b e
this [ __ ] is bananas h e y v a b e this
[ __ ] is bananas h e y b a b e this [ __ ]
is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-v-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-v-e this [ __ ] is
y
bananas
a b e this [ __ ] is bananas h e y b a b e
this [ __ ] is bananas h e y b a b a this
[ __ ] is bananas h e y b a b e this [ __ ]
is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-b this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-b this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-b this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e the [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e hey babe hey babe what are
you doing what's going on bob how's
everything good man you know i'm coming
in oh this is uh this is my new merch
for the chrissy chaos podcast
it looks like a baseball logo yes it
says cd cd and then on the back it says
distefano 84 we're going to get you some
okay um and uh you're going to going to
go to christy comedy.com and uh and and
get the merch
when we release it but yeah babe i'm
just sorry we'll have merch too soon i
was gonna say we're working on it right
now we really are maybe like in like a
month yes it'll be for sale yes it'll be
for sale very soon that's why i wore
this one to say hey the hey bay merch is
coming too it's it's just no it's it's
it's if you see this you know hey babe
ain't far behind i like it it's like we
got a little bit of a yankee thing
what's going on only four was no no
there was no 84 on the yankees right
what has happened in 84 no in 84
mattingly uh was just that was his
proper rookie year maybe yeah yes you
say because the yankees were around in
1984. yeah they were there yeah yeah
they they started in 82. i think the
yankee shot in 1982
babe i watched by the way this girl this
this
excuse my language this but this
son of a bee son of a bee this woman who
dm'd me on instagram no she didn't what
i swear to god tell me that i because
you want to tell me that because i
wanted to say what's her name what's her
name again snoop doggy samantha
okay here we go you ready for this she
dm'd you her name is samantha ramsdale
she dm me i know you've talked this is
on monday at 2 18 p.m she says i know
you've talked about the biggest mouth
guy just saying i am way funnier i can
do some pretty sick mouth tricks on your
podcast i said lol wow let me talk to
sal she said i'll see how many carrots i
could fit in my mouth or some [ __ ] and
make sal do it too we can do it side by
side
so
i wanted to bring that up did she say or
some [ __ ] or did you say that did she
write or some [ __ ] i could see how many
carrots i could fit in my mouth or some
[ __ ]
and make sal do it
wait too and then the next day well and
on april 12th i did not even realize
this on april the woman with the this is
crazy she's now in the news on april
12th she sent me a message you're an
icon huge fan would love to come on the
podcast if you ever need the largest
female gape in the world on
so she already knew she was packing but
that's insane shout out samantha ramsell
should submit i want the fans to
who doesn't want the biggest female gay
pawn listen go to email haybaypodcast
gmail.com should samantha ramsdale
female with the world's biggest mouth be
the first guest on the ebay podcast look
at this girl
wow
i don't mean to
i love her she knows what's going on i
love her she knows what's going on with
the audio audience what's going on well
if you were to just throw up a baby
picture of her
that looks like if you drew a picture
and pencil of a child
and then
and then you drew the mouth and it went
to both sides of the of the head yes and
and you'd be like and you and you you
would tell your kid like or whoever
wrote drew that be like you got to make
the mouth a little small her face if you
just pull that picture up it's a child
but then the mouth on it looks like the
mouth of a of like three adults i
literally
[Laughter]
it looks like somebody went in with the
app and like stretched her mouth an
extra like few inches on each side i am
so for doing a field piece
for me and sally babes
to go see this girl and and see how many
things we can fit
in his sexual i'm talking about food
items right right i'm talking about i'm
talking about can we fit this in her
mouth
you took my french fries cut in the
shapes of dicks yeah yes
no no no kidding i meant like look i
meant like things that she's doing like
we come out with you know we get a
burger and you know i mean that's look
at her wow
i i mean look not to revisit but she
just shattered what's his name's record
no she just shattered the kid well
that's why she messaged us she's the
biggest gape of a girl he's the biggest
gay but he messaged me saying hey like i
heard you had this other guy with the
world's biggest mouth but he he ain't
nothing
i i come have me on so that's what i'm
saying like what if we have them both on
what what if we watch them french kiss
i think the kids are minor i just oh is
it mine
but hey but listen on patreon watching
friendship no but on his 18th birthday
we can make it a pay-per-view we
couldn't make a paper uh uh i didn't
know he was a miner
he may not be softballs in her mouth i
don't mean to revisit but wouldn't you
by the way yes i did say why don't we
watch them french kiss yes did you catch
that i did yeah i'm i'm collecting
medicaid soon yes french kiss what was
that about are you are you so are you
guys going are you going with him
it's a girl we've hooked up before i
make out with yeah we made that let's
say they have a mouth off who do you
have your money on
i don't know who beats this girl to be
honest with you i don't know that the
other kid can beat this i mean look
watch this i mean look at this girl she
could she's i mean i think she has a
brick in her mouth long ways yeah i mean
because the thing is with her the other
kid seems like he can open it up
vertically she could open up
horizontally that's the difference who
wins part of this also is a little bit
weird
how big is it how big is it how big is
her mouth
they put a ruler in her mouth the
dentist but let me ask let me let me
just say something and be clear i would
never even notice she has a big mouth
until she's until she opens it until she
would you know that she has a big mouth
you mean until she fully extends it
the thing is the thing is is that when
she's talking
it seems like how big is it
6.52 centimeter from one end to the
other end like this
and you pull it apart like that so when
she's talking you see like she kind of
has a big mouth yes
but it's not until she starts to inject
things into it right that you realize
the sheer magnitude of the mouth yeah
but it was a little demeaning not
demeaning she's doing it as joking but
the guy handed her what seemed like a
giant loofah was that just rope she just
put him out that white
oh that's
a cookie she just put a wine glass in
her mouth
this girl honestly oh my god i know what
if it breaks
oh god i just got so nervous if it
shattered that would have that that is
risque capital r your idea of getting
them both on the pod is i think
the idea
if they both open their mouths we can do
like a side by side
like you ever see where like kong
yes and godzilla like are right in front
of each other like
yes and they both like growl well and
you get that like silhouette of the gap
like of their mouth so yes well here
well we need we i think we need the fans
help we have access to samantha ramsdale
yeah the other the the couple episodes
ago we talked about the the the boy with
the world's biggest mouth if anybody
knows him can they please reach out and
have him fly them in we will absolutely
on our dime 100 fly them in i got a lot
of stand up dates coming up we got
philadelphia pennsylvania almost sold
out we just added irvine improv los
angeles california at the end of
september that's on sale fort lauderdale
florida in september that's on sale
nashville foxwoods theater pittsburgh
all on sale
uh palm beach florida west palm beach
florida and phoenix arizona
chrisdcomedy.com for the tickets they're
selling out quick go get em babes go to
salvocanocomedy.com for any live dates i
have four up now i'm announcing
the entire 2022 tour
very shortly and then all the tour dates
with the impractical jokers are on sale
right now all across the country at
thetenderloins.com
fly them in not even going to require
proof of vaccine we'll just get them in
the house not even close don't worry
about it yeah we'll just get them in the
studio so i'd love to get both their
mouths on a shot and then green screen
you guys in their hole in their mouth
for a whole new logo green screen us
doing the pod live from inside their
mouth
so you you we'll get a green screen put
the like the whole tonsils here and
we're just in it yeah and we're
literally doing a full hour-long episode
from live inside their tonsils that's
unbelievable so i literally i also think
it's like
we
yeah i mean
it they
we can have a
i'm sorry i apologize i'm stroking out a
little bit right now but i have i have
so many
ideas going on in my head by the way you
look healthy your face looks thinner
yeah you right haven't you noticed that
he looks he looks down at least 10.
that's bad information though
i don't i don't think i am matter of
fact
no i'm not you're up
uh i don't know if i'm gonna buy it
sometimes when i'm having a bad couple
of weeks i don't dare stop i don't yeah
don't diss that i stepped on the scale
two days ago and it was a big mistake
but it was also an eye-opener to say
yeah chris
when you gain 15 pounds in three weeks
it's that's not great yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that's what i did but it's what
it is you live your life it's it's you
drink a lot of water i drink a lot of
water no um i think i should i should
cut my beard in half a little bit i
think that's what you're seeing right i
think that's the little illusion that
you're seeing right now
yeah so we have different items on the
table and they each get a chance to put
it in their mouth they each get a chance
and only only one will win right i mean
could you imagine they dated if they had
kids is the kid guaranteed to have like
a big mouth you think
i think the kid is guaranteed
something will be big on the kid
i think it's one of those
i think it's one of those things where
maybe they don't get the big mouth but
they get insanely big eye sockets or
they get or they get they get any
orifice they get a big yeah they
something is big they get they get
literally like uh like i'm talking about
like a medically problematic big big
butthole yeah their first one is the
biggest [ __ ] in the world it just
falls out
that they're 23 years old they have to
wear a diaper
so something happens they they like a
sandwich the sandwich just falls out
falls out because the hole is not tight
right right there's no l there's no
elasticity to it yeah elasticity
i said it wrong you mean elasticity i
think i might say elasticity and i left
off the the beginning of it oh you said
elasticity i said laxity yeah cause you
also added an x in there or a cs no i
know you knew what you meant i thought
you were saying something a word that i
was going to learn right now i think i
just i think i just what i did is i
think i combined i know that you know
what i'm relaxed yeah i think i combined
laxatives and elasticity and i came up
with laxticity and that's how slang is
is born these days and i think that what
you did was you did
what people do these days from now on i
would love the fans of the hay bay
podcast to go out there and instead of
using one of it's if you want to say
elasticity laxative or elasticity you
just say elasticity elasticity and you
just say that yeah and then let the
people who you're saying it to figure
out what you mean it's one of those
three things you know we should do maybe
lasticity is the word let's make a word
every once in a while each week i don't
know let's make a fake word that our
listeners can inject into conversation
that sounds like a real word where the
person that they're speaking to wouldn't
dare question the word and just be like
oh they must be they must have a
vocabulary set
that goes beyond my comprehension like
you ever hear someone say a word or you
ever read a word and it'd be like um
immediately when i'm reading and i see a
word i don't know the i stop reading and
i look it up in that second yes you do
that right hundred percent
or someone says it sometimes i won't be
like i'm sorry i don't know what that
means i'll just be like all right and
i'll look it up later
so let's let's start with lasticity you
know what word that is for me which i
heard yesterday watching the olympics
mercurial what is mercury mercurial what
does it mean freddie mercury i've heard
it
what is the difference
it escapes me
it means subject to sudden unpredictable
changes of mood or mind oh we're all
very curious but then we're very
mercurial volatile my girlfriend's
mercurial once a month yeah exactly
unpredictable changes oh that's
predictable then that's the definition
if it's once a month like i'll tell you
who's mercurial the damn cdc
um so by the way speaking of the
olympics now i got it the olympics
what's going on with those things you
made a controversy so you may have seen
this already but i was watched and this
has been going around uh this happened a
year ago two years ago but i was
watching diving yesterday and
here's what i learned dude i saw the
laxity of these divers i mean
laxity is not even the word they're full
of they're f it's like bolts of
elasticity right
they
what you have to do when you dive is you
have to you know do some type of
technique on the diving board that's
cool and then when you get up to the air
keep your body as compact and tight as
possible and then land in the water with
as limited splash as possible right so
that the main things in the dive are no
splash and keep your body compact and
tight right and and this happened a
little while ago but they showed what
happens when dives go wrong
you may have seen this
please google filipino diving fails you
may have seen this already you may have
seen as soon as you go but just
have you seen this yet i have not and i
have not been this excited in quite some
time okay so just keep in mind that in
order to make like to get points you
have to you have to keep your body as
tight and coiled as possible and hit the
water with limited splash so please
watch the filipino diving team attempt
this
five years ago
hit it pogo watch this
look at him watch keep going they've
shown in someone look
at this
look
at him
he gave up he came
look at his face
[Laughter]
look he gets a full zero
and look at the next guy look at the
next guy
[Laughter]
wait keep going pam let it go because
then the next guy goes in knees first
look look
no oh is that the last video
so that one so that was the first guy
that was the first guy that was so there
so wait so that was the first guy so
then they say so then they say
to the second guy they say it's all up
to him now if we're gonna make the
olympics so watch the second filipino
diver go look at this pippy look at this
guy
look this is the very next diver this is
to get into the olympics look at this
guy now
knees first he might hit me he went in
with this
[Laughter]
no splash
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god look at look it's
all on this kid
bro they got it
here he's never dove before to hit his
life this is to get into the olympics
oh my god i i'm crying look look
keep your body tight and no splash
he fully opens up his body and splashes
like he's my six-year-old he did again
there's never any compactness
[Applause]
oh my god the filipino they did not make
the olympics this year oh my god that's
the hottest i've laughed and i can't
walk
the announcements
oh my god
he's never compact you know the funniest
thing is as soon as he launches in the
air he wears the same face on the whole
thing he's like
he's like oh my god at the end right
before he hits you can tell he doesn't
know exactly where he is so he shoots
his arms out
it's like it's like he went out after he
got out of the pool and the coach was
like what are you doing he's like i
thought it was supposed to keep your
body as wide as possible maximum splash
didn't i just get all the points they're
like no body as tight as possible
minimal splash
he literally he literally i've never
cause i again i've seen that that video
go around that's that happened a few
years ago but i didn't know like what i
thought it was just about his face but
then when i was watching the diving
competition last night they said
the only way to get points is to keep
your body tight and have minimal splash
and then i saw that and was dying why
why were they why could they why did
they
they're clearly professional divers
both just took us hot [ __ ] at the same
time the filipino diving they just took
a hot [ __ ] back to back they just they
had no explanation they said after they
just said you know they just they went
on the side and they're just like
looking at you like
yeah after they said what happened out
there and he said you know clearly i had
a bad diet because i'd like to thank god
for the opportunity it says that
authorities investigated what happened
here oh my god
i would too the fact that they both it
wasn't even like they missed the dive by
a little they looked like two children
that were just at the pool like a pair
of filipino um divers have have created
a splash in more ways than one after the
footage of their botched dive at the
south east asian games in singapore
caused such a stir that that authorities
demanded answers this is now no this was
five years ago 560.
i have a splitting headache i mean it
literally just so funny they call it it
just feels funny to to refer to them as
a pear
a pair of filipino divers what do you
call two filipino divers a pear a pair
um but yeah so i just thought watching
the olympics yesterday i just thought um
it was so it looks like they slipped and
fell from like a yeah like a rooftop
yeah it just i couldn't believe that how
bad that was it was the worst but but so
yeah dude you feel if you're those
you're one of those two guys who would
you rather be first guy right i'd rather
be the sec i'd rather you make a case
that the second guy got psyched out by
the first guy and had extra pressure
because and then you can make a case
that the the first guy set the tone but
then you can make the case of the second
guy all he had to do was not do the by
the way he did the exact it looks like
that was what the dive they were trying
to do because both guys did the exact
same exact same face exact same splash
yeah it's almost like the coach of the
philippines like didn't understand
diving he was like why are my players
getting no points they did exactly what
what are you talking about knees first
yes hands in the air maximum splash for
the fans crazy face crazy green yeah i
mean have you watched some of the
olympics is so weird yeah what is this
point now sniper competition this
american kid won gold for sniping
there's like a sniper sniping
competitions they're sniping they're
countries that's great well i can't wait
great yeah we have good luck every other
country
yeah
we have a team of like 100 alternates
yeah
yeah i mean dude this is this is
watching the olympics i watched the
sprinting yesterday and some guy from
nigeria was sprinting and he just he was
losing so bad he just stopped it's funny
like they just gave up i love when they
stopped he just stopped because he was
getting i mean annihilated and he just
said that you know he just slowed he
just slowed down you you think when you
look oh he has a hamstring injury
he has no hamstrings he just just walked
it off just said you know what man
forget it how do you do that why not
just get at least your own time is going
to be affected well i guess because you
just are losing so bad was he not
running to his potential or was the
other guy just way faster no i think the
fat it's one of those ones where like
the new fastest man in the world is
actually a guy from italy yeah i saw
something so so he's just i mean he's
he's beat hussein bolt's records no he's
the fastest man of all time he's beaten
usain bolt's record yes
guy from italy
since when i don't know this guy and i
think but he's italy but his name is
like something
phillips or something it's not like an
italian he's just italians are not
represented in a lot of sports i feel
like no not what the winter games they
do like skiing and things like no i mean
in the olympics they have the italian
team i guess but i just mean in general
you never see like
like an italian athlete i mean they're
very good
marcel jacobs is the guy's name but he's
not from italy i don't know what see
that's the thing with these countries is
like like there's a guy from born and
raised in santa monica that's running
for like peru yeah you know like you you
can do it which i guess is fine but it's
like it's your heritage right it's not
like where you live yeah but but i mean
like could you go move to
italy and it could be for italy
i guess we could because you're your
lineage is italian but like a country
like let's say a new country or a
country doesn't have that many people
like could i go at the height of my
basketball career not that it was a
career but like playing college ball
could i have just lived in
qatar
for six months and just played like if i
really wanted to be in the olympics
right could is there a sport what are
the rules like could we go move to a
country that's a new sport and like try
to make the olympics in that sport you
know what i mean if so wouldn't other
countries be trying to poach people all
the time i think that they do oh i
didn't know that well i know a lot of
great athletes
especially in basketball almost all a
lot of the basketball olympics
are americans they're they're people
that that are born they just because
they can't make the american team it's
the nba so they go play for another
country now the real question for me is
i think all sports should do it should
go olympic style i'd rather see
countries play each other then yeah i'd
rather see that too because there's
something you know like when you see the
portland trailblazers even though
they're a great team with i think the
best uniforms in the game even versus my
hometown new york knicks it's like uh
portland versus new york who cares but
if it was the united states playing
the nba should be a world league got it
so you're saying that the new york
knicks are playing the tel aviv
yamaka south africa whatever the south
africa elon musks
yeah but how do you how do you form a
league that way
there's got to be all sorts of tax
implications now they have nba europe
nba africa is coming out they have nba
and also it seems like china's in charge
of the nba anyway it yeah it does seem
like that it does seem like that well
it's interesting because um
the chinese
and for the olympics medals i think the
us is still one but the chinese is very
close because the chinese like like the
by the way this guy this is another guy
he he did a false start what just
happened so okay so what happened was i
was watching this yesterday oh they
kicked him out yeah because just for the
fall because his fall start was so false
the thing is if your false start is
ridiculously false then you lose this is
the guy in nigeria in the green he just
gives up it looks like he has a
hamstring issue but at the end he says i
i s yes he just stopped
wait why would he stop but that's he's
that's the italian black italian is that
a thing i guess it is
no no there was an italian there was a
black intelligence
um but he yeah he won gold
he's multi-race and he's winning
multi-race
exactly there it is lamont marcel jacob
so he is an italian lamont marcel jacobs
is the italian that's what i'm saying
yeah he doesn't have an italian name but
let's get into his life go down a little
bit he was born in 94. he was born in el
paso texas that's cool
and he was
i was at a concert in 94 watching pearl
jam okay i was getting i i was literally
uh i had my first crush on my fourth
grade teacher mrs wasmand if you're
listening
i go back to my lebron james tech thing
where he's like
marcel jacobs here i could have dusted
him for like his first 10 years of life
100 you would have crushed him i know
when he's an infant i know yeah when do
you think he would have overtook us
probably when he when he had a growth
spurt i would think marcel could
probably have started to begin to beat
us in races when he was about 10.
he be probably dust us yeah he does this
when he's 10. how do you how do you pick
up on the fact that you just fast is he
in the house just running from room to
room with his diaper on his parents like
oh we got a cold call the olympia i
guess i guess or maybe like the body
type that always fascinates me too about
i love gotta love pimp like a track
coach how do you know you're fast how do
you know you fast you get tired how do i
how do i know if i'm running fast well
you get tired quickly and find it
difficult to complete your run so that's
mostly my everyday life um you don't
enjoy your workout and you lack
motivation well this is just speaking
directly to us yeah uh talking about
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
i actually made a meal a chicken meal
with string beans and potatoes stop yes
real speaking of hello fresh i've used
it i cook now wow that gives you
confidence right away
yet dude hello fresh
is seriously i i'm happy you're starting
to do because i've told you every week
on the show i've been doing hellofresh
i love hello fresh and i feel like a
professional chef and i love hello
friends
hello fresh hello
i feel like
i feel like i feel like the lesbian
professional chef i had sex with one
night three years ago that's how good
that that's how that's how good i feel
on hellofresh i feel like i could do her
job even though i'm sure i can
you get better value hella fresh 28
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store and 72 cheaper than a
restaurant meal without sacrificing the
quality all the other competitors are
only 69 to 71 percent cheaper and the
source is the source is the gat so you
know it's true and did i ever tell you
the time about the time i said
i said zag it i worked at my old job i
said zagging and then this this woman
who was a superior to me she couldn't
help but go it's the gas yeah well so if
you're listening and we know you are
if you are listening time for some
earmuffs because we're about to give
away the promo code about how you could
save even more right all you got to do
is go to hellofresh.com
heybabe14 that's
hellofresh.com hey babe 14 and use the
code hey babe 14 for up to 14 free meals
plus free shipping
america's number one meal kit
so can i be candid with you about
something see please i'd like to be
candid i'd like to be pleased please be
candid you need to get your teeth fixed
i know you do and where can i get my
teeth fixed well i got a place if you go
to candidco.com
yes they're the specialists and candid
it's invisible comfortable and removable
aligners above the rest for your teeth
so when you want to get your uh your
uneven
crooked teeth fixed me
you see an orthodontist yeah that's what
you do well how about now we got candid
the same orthodontist who created your
plan is with you from start to finish so
you never have to wonder how you're
doing so you canda just hooks you up
with an orthodontist they say listen
listen snaggletooth
we're gonna help you out over here i did
i chipped my tooth on the middle of high
life once it burdens me to this day it
burns
and i used to have a retainer when i was
younger i took it out i got some crooks
going on you got some crystals right now
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then and it costs thousands less
than traditional braces and with your
aligner treatment you'll get candid
teeth whitening for freebie weebie wow
and i'll start seeing results how soon
today way
way
uh way before then wow yes candy can
help you get straight or brightest smile
you've always wanted right now you can
save 75 bucks yes on your candid starter
kit when you get started from home or
you can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you today go to candidco
dot com slash hey babe and use the code
hey babe that's candid the letter c the
letter o dot com slash hey babe co hey
babe take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75 off your starter kit
can it's but i don't i think that jacobs
would be
the fastest man in the world regardless
if he just got out there and ran every
day right i just think i think for short
for running you can either do that or
you can't now let me ask you a question
do you think legitimately ask me a
question sometimes can i yes do you have
a moment i do and then we'll get to the
i love these acid wash that you got your
rock and i love your bottom
i love it
we're talking about them i love them
very nice yeah very nice very nice yeah
and then i'll reveal it or you want me
to reveal it now well i'll ask the
question okay do you believe that that
man truly is out of the 8 billion people
on the planet the fastest man
because he took the route he
acknowledged his his skill he he trained
he made the olympics and he beat him he
won in the olympics and he set the
olympic record now is there a fella rome
and the earth that was like yeah i'm
fast but olympics are not for me
do you think he's the fastest man out of
8 billion people i would i would argue i
would argue
that he is not the fastest now so you
think there's an untapped resource out
there i do
just because of the sheer amount of
number because i think there are many
people who are naturally gifted
who are extr that don't want to pursue
the olympics or sports at all but their
gifts are so that if they wanted to they
could like i firmly believe there was a
man
on in this world not right now but there
was a man at the time
when michael jordan was dominating
basketball that was a better basketball
player than michael jordan there just
has to have been you you think it's a
little bit
impossible that we are truly pinpointing
the best one person out of eight billion
i'm sure that it's happened i'm sure
that it's for real happen like so and so
do you think she has the biggest mouth
maybe not right because here's here's
what i'll tell you we're not allowed
inside north korea right what if there's
somebody in north korea that's got you
know that's got a mouth bigger than a
blue whale he could you go to north
korea and come off the runway walk into
north korea proper and there's just like
pac-man walking around 100 just like
mounts that open like that that could be
that that could be the thing and maybe
that's just a nation full of bear traps
and maybe that's why maybe we got it all
wrong with north korea maybe they're not
you know maybe they're just like you
know what we don't want anyone in here
because we're a little bit embarrassed
about the size of our mountains that's
all yeah and we need to get through that
imagine marcel jacobs rolls up one day
he's in a restaurant or a bar somewhere
and he's like people like yes for his
autograph and then the actual fastest
guy is in there and he's like
i'm pretty fast too and they do a foot
race outside and this guy devin let's
call him he dusts marcel in front of the
whole restaurant yes
i think that that is possible and it's
probable and i'm gonna go back to i
think actually the fastest man on the
planet might be living in north korea
we don't we cannot discount that they
don't have internet right
they don't have their own internet and
they're not allowed in the olympics yeah
they're not allowed in the olympics they
have no one they have their own internet
uh
i think no i don't think so they don't
even have internet they're not allowed
to look outside like they can't
it's the hermit kingdom so they can't
by the way i watched the thing on
netflix called um
the tyranny playbook or something or
tyrant something or something tyrant
something about tyrants and they go
through all
the tyrant playbook or something like
that and they go through all the
different tyrants
playbook the civil lines playbook right
um and and and they go through all the
different tyrants and they say north
korea is the number one they are the
gold medal winning group of tyrants
they've had the longest tier uh tyrant
uh dynasty in modern times they can it
seems like they will never ever the
north korean people will never ever be
able to overcome the tyranny that's
going on there every other country's
been able to be overthrown because
dictators make the same mistakes but not
the kim jong-un family they they
continuously
do
readjust and are tyrants for forever
this documentary kind of says is oon or
ill the guy now right now it's oon phil
died ill die but moon is technically oon
is currently ill
right
but but didn't something happen with oon
owen was ill
oh oon was ill
because he took the place of ill but oon
was unhealthy yes
oon is technically ill right now oon is
ill
was ill
has become ill
and while owen is ill he's currently ill
right but is oon
still ill
or was he ill for a little bit there was
like there was like there was like
murmurs that he was ill in a bad way
reported and that was all a lie reports
right now
are that oon is ill
and oon
is getting better right but is still ill
and could at some point in the near
future
not be ill anymore so who would be oon
his sister
and
okay and i think her sister will run and
her name is mary patterson
great selection of two names right here
yes i love that he married that's the
code that's comedian
[ __ ] because there's a million names you
could say yeah barry patterson worked
perfectly i wouldn't even change it and
if you want to come see me do comedy go
to christinecomedy.com
i'm back on tour we got philadelphia we
got dania point improv in in florida go
get those tickets dating a point we got
a couple of tickets left in philly only
on the wednesdays and thursdays we got
nashville we got foxwoods a big one in
foxwoods and we got west palm beach
florida and zany's nashville all christy
comedy.com check the dates we had to
cancel seattle and portland and waukegan
illinois but those will be back on the
books soon but everything else christy
comedy.com go check out the tickets i'm
coming to your city babe show your legs
they're coming they're coming to your
city that acid wash short that denim
short is coming to you that's it baby
we're coming to you your thighs are
milky white right now i know i got i
can't ever really get a tan no
no who blue tans their thighs really i
you know i don't i have jaden smith on
both eyes i keep that [ __ ] covered
i know but i
i got to get a little bit more color
speaking of color
i just want to shout out tom brady and
uh new england patriots yeah i mean they
caught not the new england patriots the
tampa bay bucks what am i saying yeah
you had a little bit of a slip i had a
slam because he's on the bucks for the
first year yes and then they go to the
super bowl and win it when it's in tampa
when it's in tampa and
also congrats i'd be remiss to not
congratulate patrick mahomes um who's
also mixed race by the way that's right
just like the man from italy maybe my
homes is italian he's fast he's the
kansas city chiefs runner-up and i think
he's got a bright future they're doing
big things over there there's a lot
ahead of them too their story's not over
their story's not over this story is
still being written congrats so congrats
to tom brady and timothy speaking of
stories still being written i'll be on
tour soon too we don't know when yet
though we don't know i just uh in 2022
looking for 60 cities here uh i'll let
you know when to look it up on my way
but the jokers are on tour we are the
guys are on tour right now the tour
starts november 19th it goes all the way
through to august more dates will even
be added it's the tenderloins.com
tour to get all the tickets we are
coming in like 50 cities and it's on
sale right now you're coming in 50
cities yeah we're we're coming 250 so i
think so we're coming in 50 cities i was
like oh that's all right well it depends
how long were there yeah yeah yeah sorry
just just because i like i want to show
off the acid wash but not that i love
you know what i love i love weather that
will allow you to wear shorts with a
sweatshirt don't you
yeah i don't know if today is the day is
today the day to do that no i don't
think so it's a little warm yeah yeah i
just i just really wanted to wear my
merch on the show i know i like it yeah
it's yeah it's fun
but but the acid wash these are from the
bare bottom who is a sponsor of hey babe
so go to bearbottom.com um and and
sponsor but this is this is um these i
love i love these shorts they got so
much cool stuff over there um all right
it's nice it looks like you're putting a
little extra effort into your outfit yes
because it's not your typical short it's
not my typical short and also i got
cactus socks on because i forgot to
mention also be in phoenix december 2nd
to the 4th christy comedy.com nice um
have you guys seen the deepest pool in
the world this is the deepest this is a
for real pool swimming pool in like a
hotel or something
awesome get out of here
how bad do you want to go there i mean
it's what i want to do after we're done
swing pool is my favorite thing in the
world has to be heated or you won't even
attempt to step in won't even attempt it
only unless it's a scorcher out there
right unless it's bringing me wonderful
wonderful comfort to chill babe yeah
i've been using copilot okay tell me
about it you know what it is it's a
fitness app i know that yes so it's a
fitness app it's a one-on-one fitness
and nutritional experience that pairs
you with a dedicated coach to form
lasting lifestyle changes because i told
you a dedicated coach dedicated and the
guy is dedicated my guy's great i had
you have a one-on-one meeting with him
and then he or she or they lay out a
plan for you and keep you accountable
that's the thing that i always struggled
with i was not chrissy accountability i
was christian no accountability this guy
every week you have a meeting with him
and he he tells you my mind's a guy and
he tells you ex you have to check in
with him provide unlimited personalized
workouts nutrition guidance constant
contact to keep you on track while being
ramon wow so it literally is like your
own
personal trainer dude the coach and he's
a real person and he sees and analyzes
every rep through motion tracking
technology it's like having a trainer
right there with you whether you're at
home in the gym or across the globe
because i told him i told him recently i
said i might be across the globe yeah at
some point what if i'm what about if i
decide to cross the globe he said no
problem out he crossed clubs we go
across the globe one-on-one personal
training usually costs 100 a session i
can vouch co-pilot only costs 69 bucks a
month so unlimited coaching and training
it's not just a great product it's a
great price it's a great price and
and it's available uh right now for
iphones which is great um oh currently
only available for iphones okay i
thought that it was available for more
than that it is just only available
right now for the ios which is fine
because if you're not if you don't have
an iphone no disrespect i mean what are
we doing here um
you're gonna get 14 days of free
training and coaching this is like you
really should do this especially if
you're somebody who's on the fence about
fitness like 14 days try this out for
two weeks and i promise you the
accountability thing i noticed that was
my biggest problem it literally can
potentially be life changing what do you
have to lose 14 days for free you can
get this for free if you go to
mycopilot.com
hey babe that's my copilot.com
hey babe
14 days of free training
why not let's do let's do it together
lose my tits i got to be honest they
just said pimp we just we just you just
hold up the pool and it said 60 meters i
don't know what that means how many feet
is it i think i don't know what 60
meters that's got to be around 180 feet
ish how do you know wait because a meter
is roughly three feet really yeah it
might be a little less or a little more
than a yard a meter is roughly three
feet i didn't know i thought
i could be wrong this is dubai dives
back into the record books with world's
deepest pool so it's in dubai which i've
never been have you been to the middle
east ever uh yesterday you went where'd
you go
dubai really yeah yeah i can't believe i
didn't see the pool interesting i know
the odds are you pulling up today it
says three million gallons of water in
there
and we got people out there you know in
our drawers that don't have water
one hour dive costs 135 to 410. so it's
basically a people are in it with scuba
gear
you know what scuba stands for right let
me take a guess you got it we all know
it from right you remember it it's in
the recesses of your brain scuba it's an
acronym swimming
is the first letter
the first word no
well you know what maybe
okay i shouldn't have told you i should
let you set it scuba scuba means
something so i'm assuming i already told
you isn't the first word okay so
scuba
um
uh uh uh it's not swimming
is it a real scientific thing or you're
saying like what i was going to say the
hint no it's not a joke
it's literally what the word scuba means
when like where it came from like the
etymology like scuba is an acronym and
every letter stands for a word and and
and you know which you know and and so
just give me the essence self
self control
underwater breathing
apparatus i think it's self-contained
but you got it wow see
we're back there right rewarding
breathing apparatus yes wow that is
that is what's in the back of my brain
right well maybe it wasn't maybe i just
was able to figure it out
well that was that was good
you're smart oh oh i wanted to actually
bring this up you just brought that up
on your own i was thinking about this
come in one mind i know we seriously
know we seriously come powers are
growing it's getting a little crazy now
i was thinking about this today i was in
the shower thinking about this before
you say that can i just want to shout
out something really quickly pimp's got
a new corduroys and these are my
favorite light purple corduroys he's
never worn those oh though those are
beautiful
what a nice hue
so the issue i ran into on the road is i
had two pair of pants i packed all the
camera stuff so i wore my pants out and
now chris is acclimating to my new pants
like purple corduroys if you can get i'd
like i'd love for you to get a shot of
yourself of them if you can and put this
in the episode but these are the best
ones i've seen these ones i'd actually
consider buying that color is gorgeous
gorgeous color i'm not even kidding it's
so pleasant thank you i feel like an
easter egg no i would put that i would
like that color looking on furniture or
something yeah i was going to say one of
the walls in in in one of the kids rooms
were going to paint that color oh that's
really nice all right let's go ahead i'm
sorry yeah i also i like that you do a
wide corduroy too oh yeah because
everybody's about wide and thin
everybody no not even the leg the actual
corduroy
is a wide
it's a thick corduroy because you're
because i'd be nervous to wear that
because i say i don't want to look i
don't want to look wider but pimp says
bring on the wide pimps
let's go i used to rock corduroy's like
nobody's business i swear i was a
corduroy guy i had like five pairs of
quarters swear to god five different
pairs of quotes roy rogers all the time
quarter roy rogers that's a good
nickname for you too go to roy rogers
roy ross pimp from now on his quarter
roy rogers
or quarter roy wood jr yeah
we also said i dress how joe derosa
decorates his apartment yes
yes yes we did it we did a taste buds
and a hey babe yes which you've seen by
now which they've seen which guys seem
right now that was in joe derose's uh
that was in joe derose's apartment which
i couldn't believe what joe derosa's
apartment even though he's a pig i
couldn't believe how joe derosa of
course is comedian our friend on the no
pressure network i do taste buds with
him yes the other podcast if you haven't
seen that what are you guys doing what
are you tuning in to the other podcast
joey butterscotch
so so joe's apartment even though i
still want to tell you that he's a pig
and belongs in a stable or pigsty his
apartment is so neat and clean so well
kept it organized and so cute
it really made me kind of look in the
mirror and say you got to do better
chris wow did you tell him this no of
course i won't tell him this because he
said he doesn't watch hey babe
so you better not tell me nobody watches
anybody what do you think we have all
the time in the world we have to sit
here and do this
yeah it'd be funny if i watched both
yeah
literally yeah you watch them all
one of the fans wrote in the comments
shout out this fan how many paintings of
clowns does one adult need
joe joe if you just you guys by now
you've seen the episode two weeks ago
you gotta love you gotta love a guy a
just a bachelor who has a red leather
couch red leather red leather i mean
he's straight up like yes that is
bachelor bad like if i was a woman
coming into that apartment i said oh
this guy means business supple fire
engine red leather where the leather can
be
i mean it's all you need to know about
joe he's a mover he's a shaker shaker
you know i mean he's he's he's he's
slick slick slick joe slick show and
right above it an insane clown and
insane
an oil painting of an insane clown and
then he cooked us meatballs and pork
that was exquisite with this i didn't
eat them you didn't like it i didn't
like it why didn't i see this clip
someone sent me a clip couldn't eat the
pork i know you didn't like the pork
chop here too no i like the pork chop
here people are calling oh that's what i
saw in the comments yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like the pork chop here better but i
can't wrap my head around eating i don't
know why the pork and goat cheese still
bothers me the pork chop we had that day
was not the pork chop i really wanted
you to have it was good it was good i
still thought that pork chop was better
than joe's pork shoulder even though
joe's pork shoulder was insane was
amazing joe's meatball with the sauce
was one of the best meatballs and sauce
i've ever had no no joe is a fantastic
cook okay he really genuinely i thought
you were like didn't like it no no i
didn't like the pork the meatball that
he gave me with the sauce was fantastic
okay i just don't like pork not a pork
guy i'm not a poor guy i'm porky
yeah
you know yeah i'd like you know i if i
was single i'd say let's pork
you know oh yeah and also shout out joe
is his birthday today is joe's birthday
no it's coming up oh it's coming up you
know it's his birthday is in uh two days
we're going outside oh it'll be it'll be
on yeah i'm gonna be there we'll all be
there it doesn't matter it doesn't hey
and we're going and and sorry you missed
us sunday we were hanging out at the
stand yeah
you could have seen all of there was a
blast we had a great time man you're
you're with a with a lady right yes and
she says to you
uh
you're at dinner right and then you're
like i don't know where this is going
after this and she leans into you and
she goes i want a
pork are you like
ah
i don't know if i want to
to do that with this person she used the
word pork unironically she's not being
facetious
okay she's being dead serious she says i
really want wanna pork i think i gotta
take it i think i gotta think about that
i'll tell you this who is this person
pork
pork is tough man she was mad she goes
to a friend she's like
i can't even she's like i porked this
guy up last night i just i pork who's
who says pork i just poured one of the
guys i just poured a guy from the
podcast i said i would say excuse me who
says pork pork was that like a 70s thing
to be honest with you at this point if
you if you to be honest with you if you
said to me hey hey or you somebody said
hey i just i just got porked i would
think that it was somebody hit you with
a pork chop like it was a prank thing
like a tick tock thing i don't know
about popped in the face with him like
it's a thing on like i said what do you
mean pork like on tick tock because it'd
be so out of the lexicon right you know
of of sex i'd be like that has to be a
new tick tock thing that we're getting
out of your pocket people you wouldn't
connect it to
i wouldn't because there's so much
you know somebody in their 50s my mom or
dad might right you know i'd be like i
parked your mom last night right right
because they understand lexicity yes
they understand like the electricity of
the world
here's another thing everyone listening
take this opportunity this week to use
pork as a verb with someone that you
know and just see what their reaction is
and sound off in the comments just go or
email us oh you got did we did we get
all those emails about the merch ideas
oh we got tons of emails okay can you we
gotta i gotta i need to log in we gotta
get on that yeah we gotta do that we're
gonna do that because here's the thing
here's the thing is we we're now on hey
babe week after week we're gonna start
giving you homework so your homework
today is to is to use in a sentence or
even have a video of you using laxity
and pork and you can email that you can
either tweet that video at the heybay
pod or email it to heybaypodcast
gmail.com correct well maybe we'll even
bring up one of the best videos of
somebody using laxity and pork because
here's the thing
here's the thing
if the cdc is going to tighten up so are
we on hey babe that's right we're
tightening up and we're going to give
you homework week in and week out we're
tightening up the range this is the new
regime do you want to be part of this do
you not want to be part of it whatever
you want to be on the inner circle yeah
by the outskirts yeah the end of cirque
de soleil i'm sorry i cut you off about
ashton kutcher and mila kunis they don't
bathe wow they don't bathe and neither
do their children
that's the top line okay they bathe like
once a week and i look we've all heard
the stories your body has natural oils
you're not supposed to wash your hair
every day you're stripping it of it it's
essentials i've heard it i've seen the
articles blah blah blah
the fact of the matter is they abide by
it and they go in hard they say they
don't even touch their kids unless they
see physical dirt on them which as a
baby i get and they say they shower but
just the uh
just the groin and like the pits and
stuff so my dermatologist told me shout
out dr patel my dermatologist told me
you should really only be washing you
really only have to legally wash your
armpits and your genitalia well this is
what ashton and mila kunis he said you
don't really have to worry they're
within the part of your body yeah so so
what we're doing might be i mean we're
doing something not illegal he said you
don't have to
you should you gotta get the dirt off
your face does that mean there's a big
shower
like is there a big shower that's
pushing all this stuff
[Laughter]
no shower i mean the shower people hate
this
they hate this they hate this
oil of i mean yeah dove soap is like
they're they're they're they want to
cancel ash and cook i got a scrub babe i
got a scrub i got i don't you know what
take my oils take it i need to go in
there i need to lather up i need to i
need to steam up i need to lather up i
need my pores open i need all sorts of
scrubs lotions i need all that stuff i
need to come out feeling like a million
bucks at least once a day babe my
response to that is same sickles i'm in
the same boat because here's what i'll
tell you even this i don't know if
you're like this or a pimp if you're
like this every time if i take three
showers a day every shower i wash my
hair i want if i'm in the shower and
water's hitting my body i'm i'm washing
my body and shampooing and conditioning
my hair it doesn't i could do it i'll do
it three times and doesn't the
conditioner help
maintain the essential oils
or they say you could go in and just use
conditioner i tried it once or twice
because i wanted to see what all the
hubbub was about and i didn't have the
body bouncing shine that i normally have
interesting yeah how many showers a day
do you have i do okay i do one a day
sometimes in summer months or if i'm
coming from an activity
i've done two you know um and then if
i'm like home for an extended period of
time like a three-day weekend and i
didn't leave the house i might skip a
day
if i'm just like i never got out of my
sweats on my pajamas and the next day i
do it right but you know i'm a generally
a once a day guy you're watching while
and then in the morning or at night
because it's really nice to take one at
night before bed but if i take one at
night before bed
i gotta take one again in the morning me
too i can't just wake up and get dressed
out of bed without chatting i literally
was almost late to the pond today
because even though i had you know slept
with the air conditioner was on high
yeah i did not sweat at all i was like
should i shower should i not should i
shower should i not i said i have to
take a five second shower i just have to
shower before i go before i go to the
pod yeah and you know my family was like
what are you shot like you don't need to
shower you're late i said i just i was
already i'm talking about i already have
these clothes on yeah and i took them
off and showered yeah because i need to
i would pr i would propose that you and
i do an ashton and mila and then don't
shower
except the parts until next time and
then see how it goes but i can't even
commit to that how about this i can't do
it all the fans out there i want you
guys to not shower for a week and then
email to heybaypodcastgmail.com the
pictures of your best rash the best rash
we will retweet whoever gets the the
biggest source
sound off in the comments
i love saying that sound uh
uh uh if like mila and ashton if you if
you're listening and we know that you
are uh uh we we we appreciate you guys i
would love to talk to you and interview
you about this but sound off in the
comments about how many showers a week
that you take and what's the longest
you've ever gone without a shower right
and what came of that but what we really
want though is is we want videos of you
guys using laxity and pork
in a sentence we don't want the other
person to know we want to see how they
react to both lexicity and pork
any which way you want to do it you want
it to be your wife your barista your
brother your
barista uh i think it's either what do
you think it is pimp i like barista i
like barista i think it's probably
barista
but i said barista typically barista
i don't think i've ever even said
barista
no i said just that moment it doesn't
matter what if you're male female
trans i say the coffee guy always which
i know i should do better at and i
apologize to the community just if this
is just there's a 20 like a 19 year old
girl there with a pony tell you like the
coffee guy has my order it could be a
six-year-old
filipino girl i'd say the coffee you
know i got it from the coffee guy
they've been having me put my prince
herb
uh i had to go by prince herb like in
public so when i get my coffee at
starbucks i have to say like i put i put
prints on there really because i had to
record it and send it in
they want to see it happening still
they used to yeah they have to say
whatever you say on that by the way yeah
the barista has to say whatever name you
put on that really yeah because i put my
old nickname was jakrispy yeah from the
show and i put it on all the time and
they would be like you're crispy you're
crispy yeah yeah
i've never seen this happen before i
forgot to tell you this last week you
know because i've had to keep going back
and forth la you know to new york to do
uh backyard bar wars every thursday 10
30 uh hashtag bbw right after an all new
and practical jokers 10 o'clock thursday
thursdays are for the babes all over
yeah true tv podcast everything but so
i'm you know keep going back and forth
so finally finally the last episode of
becker bar wars is filmed and loved the
show but just saying i needed to get
back to new york i just missed home so
much i i hated even having the thought
of i have to leave again in two weeks i
just want to be home i just want to be
home and so finally the very last day we
filmed the episode i'm on a 10 p.m
red-eye flight and i'm finally like text
my family i'm coming home coming home
this has never happened before in my
life on a flight how many i've taken
thousands of flights
we literally
go out like out pulling back i'm like
we're just pulling back and going
airplane mode whatever like we're coming
out
airline pilot says you know coming out
uh you know whatever you know gives you
all the updates five hours in the air
whatever it is coming out
we're literally like out like going on
the run on the run
we're
actually like about like we make that
turn and we're actually like speeding up
to take off the pilot slams on her
brakes legitimately like slams on her
brakes and comes over the pa and says
this has been hay bay
that [ __ ] is bananas h-a-y-a-i-e-a-b
this [ __ ] is bananas
h-e-y-b-a-b-e that [ __ ]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey